I'm going to kill everyone you love
there's nothing you can do about it
just the the mention of Wilson face is
so frightening and sinister I loved
playing this character so much there's a
lot to him and it's just so much fun so
the devil is back the character that
Vincent created is become so iconic
so having back is absolutely thrilling
this is such a great rivalry between the
two of us I'm gonna find a way to bring
Fisk down it's not gonna be pretty
Vincent is phenomenally talented at
bringing dimension to the role we see
his downfall in season one now we're
going to see the return and the rise of
kingpin if Fisk stays out of prison not
even as some people are gonna die
he starts in prison and he's not happy
pup
Fiske is a master at manipulation Fisk
has been playing us he literally is
always three four five steps ahead of
Matt's best thinking well that's what
Fisk us finds a weakness hits it hard it
paves the way into kingpin taking the
city back over again have a little faith
in me
the driving force behind everything this
season is this idea that this man must
be soft once and for all even if it
costs me my everlasting soul I wanted to
make sure that fans said oh yes we're
back to Wilson Fisk and vigilante Matt
I'm excited for the fans to see what
we've done
[Music]
that's it let the devil out since the
first season people have been waiting
for it so they're just gonna flip
you
you